sikhism comes into being in northern
india in a time when the moguls are
coming to power
what we see in this blue area is what
the first mughal emperor babar is able
to put under his control which includes
the region of punjab which is where
sikhism begins and thrives to this day
we see later emperors like akbar
continuing to expand the domain of the
mughal emperor with aurangzeb the least
tolerant of the moguls expanding well
into south india
it all starts in the 15th century with
the birth of who will eventually be
known as guru nanak he's born into a
merchant class hindu family and he's
known to be precocious from a very young
age especially when it comes to matters
of spirituality
he's constantly questioning he goes and
learns about various religions remember
north india is under the control of the
muslims but it's a hindu majority
population and you also have populations
of christians and jains and this is also
a time as we've studied in other videos
where the bhakthi movement is on the
rise this notion of devotional love to
god within hinduism and it's in this
context that guru nanak becomes a
significant some would say bhakthi guru
to get a sense of some of his teachings
there is but one god his name is truth
he is without hate he is beyond the
cycle of births and deaths he is
self-illuminated so just in this excerpt
of some of his sayings you see elements
of the core of hinduism and elements of
islam there is but one god a central
tenet of islam
but then these ideas that really come
from a vedic tradition god is beyond the
cycle of births and debts samsara he is
self-illuminated there is a lot of
mention of your inner self your true
self is one with this god
even kings and emperors with heaps of
wealth and vast dominion cannot compare
with an ant filled with the love of god
so here you see this bhakthi influence
and you can see why he is considered a
major bhakti guru or bhakthi saint he's
emphasizing this devotional love of god
the world is a drama staged in a dream
so here you have the hindu the vedic
notions of maya the world is an illusion
his followers will eventually be known
as six and the word sikh comes from the
sanskrit word for to learn or learning
and it's related to the word for student
and even in modern sanskrit derived
languages like hindi you have words like
sikhna which means to learn
guru nanak dies in the early 16th
century and you can see by this point
the moguls have taken control of
northern india
and before his death he names guru angad
who is not his son as his successor
after guru angad you have guru amardas
and then you have guru ramdas who
establishes the city now sacred to seeks
known as amritsar originally known as
ram dasapur
guru ramdas is succeeded on his death by
guru arjan and guru arjan is significant
for many reasons he creates the
compilation known as the adi granth
which are the sayings and the hymns of
the previous gurus including his own the
adi grant as we will see will eventually
evolve into the guru granth sahib which
is considered not only the sikh holy
book but also the last and final of the
gurus in ram das poor later to be known
as amritsar guru arjan
builds the harmander saab which is
intended to be a place of worship for
people of all religions they have a
tradition of longer where they feed
anyone who comes from any faith and
today the harmandar sahib would later be
known as the golden temple where later
raja would plate it with gold is the
largest free kitchen in the world guru
arjun is also known as the first martyr
in the sikh faith as we've talked about
the early moguls were relatively
tolerant akbar in particular was
extremely tolerant but upon his death
his son jahangir takes power and early
in jahangir's reign he is insecure about
his hold on power and remember the
moguls are ruling from the same region
where the sikhs are having an
increasingly growing following not just
from hindus but also from muslims
threatened by this growing following
jahangir imprisons guru arjan and
tortures guru arjan trying to get him to
renounce the faith to convert to islam
gurarjan refuses despite many days of
excruciating torture being boiled alive
eventually he dies and there's slightly
varying accounts of how it happens
after his death his son who will be
known as guru har gobind comes to power
and guru har gobind as legend has it on
direction from his father before he
would die
tells him that the sikhs need to
protect themselves they need to adopt a
military tradition to protect themselves
from the oppression especially the
oppression from the moguls
and so guru hargobind he is famous for
establishing the military tradition of
sikhism he is the first guru to be what
you could call a warrior saint he is
famous for wearing two swords
one to represent his authority in the
spiritual realm and another to represent
his authority in the temporal realm he
also has the longest tenure as guru
at guru hargobind's death his grandson
guru harai becomes guru at his death his
very young son guru har krishna becomes
guru but dies of smallpox after which
guru hargobind's youngest son becomes
guru
he is named eventually guru tegh bahadur
which means brave sword or brave wielder
of the sword because as his father guru
hargobind fought the moguls he was known
as being unusually brave and an
unusually competent warrior he continued
this tradition of being a warrior saint
and especially under the rule of shah
jahan and aurangzeb as the moguls became
more and more intolerant and started
force conversions he viewed himself as a
protector of the oppressed not just of
the sikhs but the oppressed of any fates
including hindus who were being forced
to convert by aurangzeb eventually
aurangzeb tortures and kills him for
refusing to convert to islam and he is
considered the second guru who is
martyred at his death
we have the 10th and last human guru of
the sikh tradition guru gobind singh
who continues again this tradition of a
warrior saint and actually formalizes it
in this notion of khalsa there's a
famous story of him gathering the sikh
community and asking for volunteers and
the first volunteer he takes into a tent
and then he emerges from that tent
without the volunteer with a bloody
sword giving people the impression that
he might have killed that individual
then he asks for more volunteers and
more people come and every time he comes
out of the tent without the volunteers
but with a bloody sword but after five
volunteers have come they all emerge
from the tent he makes it clear that
this was an exercise as a test of faith
to see who was willing to risk their
life to follow the cause and he says
these are the khalsa these are the pure
together
we are going to be
a group to fight oppression wherever it
might be
and he formalizes what it means to be
one of these warrior saints famously
with the five k's of khalsa that anyone
who goes into the khalsa indoctrination
who becomes a khalsa sikh
they should not cut their hair this is
known as kesh they should wear a metal
bracelet known as kara they should have
a wooden comb known as kanga and they
should carry a short dagger sword known
as kirpin and there's kachara which is
often an undergarment warn and has
symbolic meaning
a man who goes through the khalsa
ceremony the khalsa baptism
adopts the title of sing which means
lion and a woman who does adopts the
title core or princess and it's
essentially they are promising to fight
oppression wherever it might be
guru gobind singh is also famous for the
final compilation of what would be known
as the guru granth sahib
taking the adi grant which was compiled
by guru arjan and adding the 115 hymns
of guru tegh bahadur who was martyred
and making this collection of hymns not
just from the gurus but from
saints and gurus in the hindu and muslim
tradition as well and declaring that
this is the 11th and final guru and
sikhs today view the guru granth sahib
as their guru if you were to visit a
gurdwara which is their temple it means
door to the gurus dwara same route in
sanskrit as door you will see it houses
a guru granth sahib which the sikhs will
venerate and view as their guru